05-9 was having a lazy morning after all
while being a member of the o5 council
is a demanding job it doesn't mean that
you don't occasionally have off days his
schedule was clear so he decided to
catch up on some youtube videos he'd
been meaning to watch water his plants
and play some office golf to ease off
the boredom that's when he received a
strange message from 05-1 on the closed
o5 council communications relay network
it read 9 attached off files we found
last week within site-01 steepwell i
wouldn't trouble you with this if not
for the fact that the events described
herein have never occurred their initial
creation date is approximately 50 000
years back please familiarize yourself
with them as quickly as possible and
just like that 05-9's lazy day had been
torpedoed he put away his golfing
equipment and accessed the file
strangely it read accessing file
scp-6789
iteration 1 30 0 8 18 25. you can
probably see the inconsistency already
50 000 years ago and 1825 don't make for
the most congruent timeline this would
definitely warrant further exploration
even if it meant eliminating his chances
of a fun office golf day the file
described an anomalous presence in a
room beneath the rolander general steel
factory in chestahova poland where the
speed of organic material growth is
absurdly fast in a manner similar to the
growth stimulated by the neutralized
anomaly
scp-407 also known as the song of
genesis however the anomaly itself
didn't concern o5-9 nearly as much as
its location chestahova poland perhaps
not the first place on anyone's dream
vacation destination list but one of the
most important anomalous locations in
the world we're gonna need to take a
minute to explain a few key concepts to
you namely the concept of freeport
asterberg and site-120 you see while it
is the foundation's prerogative to
secure and contain anomalies where they
might intersect with humanity and thus
threaten the upholding of consensus
reality there are certain places where
doing so just isn't practical or
possible they're big places sometimes on
our dimensional plane sometimes residing
in others with large and largely
anomalous populations to borrow an
example from the foundation files
picture a new york city where everyone
inside is a mix of fae aliens animal
people magic practitioners or the undead
a full anomalous community permanently
situated in a given location it's two
separate and secluded enough from
humanity to necessitate full containment
and if we're being realistic the
foundation couldn't contain them without
a great deal of hassle anyway a location
like this is known as a nexus however
particularly large nexuses that also act
as hubs of anomalous trade and commerce
are known as freeports freeports are a
complicated situation for the scp
foundation in a bureaucratic sense
international and interdimensional law
forbid the foundation from intervening
in the matters of freeports without
proper permission these places are
highly autonomous zones with their own
internal laws and law enforcement
freeports often exist on separate planes
of existence and can only be entered
through anomalous means meaning
accidental interactions with humans from
freeports are extremely unlikely
therefore in these special autonomous
zones the veil can be entirely lifted
one such freeport is the city of
esterberg designated
scp-5373 by the foundation which is a
particularly special case it's the
largely entirely anomalous city that is
not under foundation control it has a
high fey population hence its name which
means city of the east in the fae
language it is an immensely powerful and
important place where magic and reality
bending are just parts of everyday life
and as you've probably intuited at this
point being the smart good-looking and
charismatic fans of scp explained the
free port of esterberg is situated in a
pocket dimension directly parallel to
chestahova poland this brings us to site
120. scp foundation chesterhoeian
research and reliquary dimensional
containment facility abbreviated to site
120 is a unique location as far as
foundation facilities go for starters
it's built on an abandoned industrial
facility on top of a different anomalous
nexus scp-5292
also known as the library of babel this
is a huge interdimensional library
complex heavily associated with the fey
containing a countless number of ancient
volumes written in languages unknown to
humankind this feels like an apt
metaphor for the primary purpose of site
120 and its staff bridging the gap
between the foundation and anomalous
communities like the freeport of
esterberg and it should come as a
surprise to nobody that this is one hell
of a gap the population of estherberg
largely distrusts fears or outright
despises the scp foundation given that
their typical attitude to anomalies is
less brotherly love and more getting
black bagged by a mobile task force and
carried off to a paranormal black site
they have somewhat of a reputation for
being gun hoe brutes or jailers as the
serpent's hand likes to refer to them
that's why site 120 has a very delicate
diplomatic situation on its hands and to
deal with this situation they created a
specialized task force known as the
inter-species communications team with
27 well-trained researchers negotiators
and diplomats headed by dr anna schloss
they're doing all they can to extend the
anomalous olive branch to the
communities within estherberg and
improve the foundation's standing among
them so needless to say the situation
over in chestahova poland is exceedingly
complicated and as o5-9 read further
through the document on
scp-6789 he just hoped that they weren't
all staring down the barrel of a future
diplomatic or containment snafu though
05-9 had no idea just how crazy
everything was going to get with
scp-6789
at first the anomaly seemed pretty
straightforward it was confined to an
unlit sub-basement boiler room in the
rolling der general steel factory
however despite the lack of light or
really any of the conditions necessary
for supporting life that isn't insects
or fungus a glorious flourishing
microcosm has developed down there flora
and fauna abound and seem to be
developing safely in a complete
ecosystem workers and foundation
researchers upon entering this area
reported hearing a low thrum similar in
sound and rhythm to a heartbeat all
around them though this sound hasn't
been recorded outside the claims of
those who supposedly experienced it
firsthand workers of the steel mill
reported feeling a tremendous sense of
calmness and wonder while inside
scp-6789 they would walk into the boiler
room whenever they felt stressed between
shifts and watched sprouts growing up
around their feet in real time and small
animals like rabbits and hairs hopping
out what seemed like nothingness it was
a place of wonder a gift from mother
nature herself an opportunity to feel
the warmth and the rhythm of her very
beating heart however this ran into
problems when the plant growth
obstructed the operations of the steel
mill shutting down its main boiler this
led to the rolander general steel
company pressuring one thomas williams
head of the technical repair team to
effectively destroy
scp-6789 and install a new boiler where
it had one spin when he expressed
reluctance to trample on this hollowed
ground they threatened his job and the
livelihood of his family with great pain
and reluctance he followed through with
their destructive orders during a
foundation exit interview williams
tearfully recounted
i didn't want to
they said they'd come after my staff my
family cut our wages
i
i torched the room
tore out the old machine and put the new
one in
my men hated me for it called me a
monster for what i made them do the
sounds that place made whilst it burned
i don't know what drove me to defile
such a gift of nature
greed or fear or both you will let me
know if anything happens down there
won't you
i need to know if it can regrow
it must be able to right and in the
strange twist of fate
scp-6789 did begin to come back and even
stranger it began to expand further
causing unchecked growth in the rooms
around the boiler room studies at the
time noted that the growth was
accelerating by a pace of 0.6 meters
every 24 hours but of course this was
only the beginning
by the year 1947 the majority of the
city of chestahova poland had been
consumed by an ever-evolving scp-6789
not only had the growth rate been
increasing exponentially but the actual
anomalous effects of the
scp-6789 field were becoming more varied
and powerful plants as high as 20 meters
in height were bursting out of the
ground observers noticed significant
differences between the plants within
the
scp-6789 area of effect and the ones
outside suggesting the results of
millions of years of evolution being
achieved in a mere handful of decades it
didn't take long for 70 of the city to
be consumed leading to a mass evacuation
from a distance the energy field of
scp-6789 is visible around the city
appearing almost like a huge translucent
dome capping it from overhead though
tests have revealed that the other side
of a massive energy sphere stretches
beneath the earth's crust being inside
the energy field can be dangerous for
non-anomalous civilians as the plants
have a strange memetic effect of
inducing unconsciousness in anyone
within a cognitive resistance value crv
of less than 20. this pernicious effect
has resulted in the loss of almost 99 of
the civilian population though we should
specify they are not dead on the
contrary the people knocked unconscious
within scp-6789
enter a state of stasis where their
health gradually improves without the
need for nutrition a team from mtf
epsilon 3 also known as the atypical
philosophers was sent into the belly of
the beast on a recon mission to
re-establish contact with site-120 which
was one of the first areas to be taken
over by the ever-expanding
scp-6789 the team members marveled at
the transformed world within the energy
sphere it had been reclaimed entirely by
mother nature transforming it into a
world that seemed at once alien and
familiar as they progressed deeper
within they couldn't help but feel an
odd sense of tiredness taking over
eventually they reached and breached
site 120 on the inside the site staff
were cocooned in bizarre translucent
pods that seemed to have a rejuvenating
effect they also couldn't help but
notice the loud thrumming heartbeat that
echoed throughout the facility however
before they could successfully call in
reinforcements the memetic effects of
scp-6789 took over each of them
collapsed to the ground falling
unconscious to get a better look at some
of the flora and fauna within scp-6789
a foundation researcher kept a
comprehensive record of notes of some of
the various plants and animals of
interest she recorded within the
affected area upon seeing a flock of
several thousand flying birds she noted
if we can find a way to study
scp-6789's methods we may be able to
find a practical use for the anomaly i
have not seen a flock this size since my
childhood from before the war it brought
back memories i thought i'd never feel
again i will speak to my superiors for
more resources after seeing a group of
eurasian brown bears hunting a herd of
thompson's gazelle she noted this
confirms
scp-6789 is capable of producing species
foreign to europe it should be noted
that this creates the potential for
catastrophe we can no longer comfortably
predict what might come out of there
after seeing some nesting formerly
extinct flightless birds known as the
great ock she wrote down we spotted the
birds from the boat when major bialys
our resident ornithologist heard a bird
call she did not immediately recognize
we soon spotted the great ox on the
cliffs nursing their young this confirms
scp-6789 is capable of bringing back
extinct species but to what extent and
by what means could we somehow harness
this power to turn back our own aging
upon seeing the incredible herd
comprised of thousands of specimens from
an extinct bovine species known as the
rocks she noted magnificent i thought
the large mammals of europe were all but
extinct our expedition encountered the
herd moving north along the river
towards ponzan but we managed to
intercept them and kept them within
scp-6789
zone after seeing a series of
genetically mutated kapok trees that
grew so fast they destroyed the
surrounding foundation research centers
she noted in light of recent incidents
further expeditions into
scp-6789 have been indefinitely
suspended sufficient information has
been gathered regarding
scp-6789's capabilities and practical
use continued research has been deemed a
waste of foundation resources a
controlled burn of the plant growth has
been authorized by the high council upon
confirmation of the anomaly's
annihilation
scp-6789 will be reclassified as
neutralized but of course it was never
going to be that easy was it by the year
1989
scp-6789 had claimed the entirety of
poland things had gotten so severe that
the foundation needed to use a
custom-made anti-meme in addition to
mass applications of amnestics and
efforts to scrub all references to the
country from recorded media to
completely wipe any memory of poland's
existence from the global consciousness
while they tried to solve this
scp-6789 situation but the prospect of
any such solution began to seem more and
more like using a band-aid to cure a
decapitation as things spiraled out of
control at first the foundation could
curtail the growth of the 6789 area
through controlled burns with
thermaturgically enhanced fire this
however did not impact the continued
growth for long researchers predicted
that an ik class collapse of global
civilization scenario could potentially
occur in as little as seven months
however while these developments were
all a net minus for humanity they
created wonderful opportunities for a
few species that humanity had wronged in
the past the children of the forest a
subset of the fae that was wiped out
after the battle at the factory and the
children of the night better known as
scp-1000
or bigfoot surviving members of
inter-species communications team from
site 120 attempted to start a dialogue
with these cultures forming in the
ever-growing
scp-6789 area that was once poland
however given the incredibly fractious
history between humanity and these two
groups they were not met with a warm
reception repeated attempts to enter the
domain of scp-1000 and communicate with
them were met with the following series
of aggressive communique from the
children of the night do not attempt to
contact at the time no reason to trust
we will respond with force all entry
into our reclaimed terrain will be
understood as a violation of this
request stop all attempts we see your
attempts we will not warn again
cease mother does not wish for us to
meet with you we therefore listen do as
she says or meet the consequences it's
probably clear by this point that the
scp foundation was barking up the wrong
genetically mutated kapok tree they had
burned their bridges with all these
specimens with their own selfish actions
and would never again be seen as friends
to them however some answers were
provided by a child of the night that
was at least willing to speak to them in
english even though he resented
everything they stood for he informed
them that they had invoked the very
wrath of mother nature with their
terrible actions and now they were
taking revenge in his chilling closing
statement he said look what you did to
us look what you did to the children of
the forest we forgave you your siblings
gave up on fighting back but your
mother's heart is broken she gave you
life and you showed her your true colors
the moment she let you off her leash she
birthed you yet you chose to portray her
in the most disgusting way possible get
out there and wait as mother nature does
her job at neutralizing your poison she
didn't give up on you no not yet unlike
yourself that is and of course it would
only get worse from there by 2066 it was
all over the ever-expanding
scp-6789 had consumed almost the entire
planet leaving the surviving foundation
population to seek what remained of
refuge on a boat said permanently adrift
all they could do was watch as mother
nature claimed her vengeance against the
human race and took over the earth while
they planned desperately against her the
beating heart of
scp-6789 developed roots that reached
way down into the depths of the earth
giving it access to life everywhere much
like the scp-1000 specimen had said it
seems plausible that this entity was the
source of all life on earth our one true
mother of north america the foundation
wrote following
scp-6789's manifestation in the north
american continent yellowstone base has
been lost with all personnel having been
evacuated before the spread of
scp-6789 into the duchy of wyoming
scp-2000 remains accessible through
direct portals as
scp-6789 structures do not appear to
have penetrated the insides of the
underground complex housing it it is
unknown why this occurred considering
scp-6789's attraction to machinery
similar to other foundation sites
worldwide yellowstone base has lost its
main purpose the great yellowstone super
volcano which was once monitored and
restrained has been noted to cease
volcanic activity most nearby areas
previously thought to be inhospitable
have been healed and are populated by
wild flora and fauna alike of libya they
wrote the main difference between
pre-scp 6789 libya and post was the
total destruction of more than 274
industrial complexes which were once the
country's pride of note is the total
decontamination of the connection
between the libyan ocean and the
mainland this change has been so extreme
that even the devil's throat is now
clear of all traces of oil contamination
similarly the great libyan canal is once
again accessible through the european
strait despite once being blocked by
industrial waste for more than 27 years
of antarctica they wrote despite the
extreme harsh environment created by the
antarctic empire
scp-6789 growths did not struggle with
adapting to the conditions in actuality
most flora megastructures spawned around
the country were noted to be the largest
on record growths were noted to be
universally dense regardless of human
development unlike previous trends the
only exception to this rule was the
complete destruction of the country's
floating capital it's theorized that
this was caused by the city's proximity
to the ozone hole of poland where it all
began they wrote being the origin point
for the entire anomaly poland's entire
area is dense with
scp-6789 flora despite this the most
compact area is the core itself the
ceiling void ship their numerous
formations and structures which do not
appear to be present anywhere else in
the world are located examples include
trees larger than 100 meters in height
or half transparent biological domes
acting as insulative barriers for the
most polluted areas all such places have
been noted to heal much more quickly
with instruments noting that poland's
once poisonous groundwater is now at an
almost perfect level of quality fish and
other water life have since repopulated
these waterways as they did before the
industrial revolution of the remote
tuvolo states they wrote the situated
noted in the tuvalu states is certainly
the most unusual though not because of
what most would expect throughout the
entire country almost no plants exist
large tracts of land consistently
possess almost no growths whatsoever the
tuvalu states account for more than 75
percent of the planet's surface that has
yet to succumb to scp 6780
the only parts of the country that have
been affected are the highly populated
industrial complexes though these
account for less than point zero zero
zero zero one percent of the country's
area although an attempt was made at
establishing a foundation base within
tuvalu all expeditions were met with
failure due to resistance from
scp-6789 towards all construction
efforts further plans were stopped once
foundation naval base zero one was
designated as humanity's safe haven as
time went on the dwindling 05 council
dropped off one by one tried their best
to implement some method of fighting
back some of the many many failed
attempts included via the usage of
foundation physicists thalmaturgists and
theologists
attempt to contact the deity located
within
scp-6789's core use foundation rituals
to imprison reason with destroy or
otherwise neutralize the entity and via
the usage of a foundation-developed
anomalous disease specific to
scp-6789's floral structures attempt to
reclaim critical foundation bases and
habitation centers resume previous
containment efforts once successful all
that seemed to be left was the nuclear
option attempt 67 the bottom of the file
read via the usage of project lethe and
kolade memetic triggers revert
humanity's state of development to
pre-industrial times through the
degradation of brain development rob
humanity of thousands of years of
scientific cultural and technological
development await total destruction of
modern infrastructure by scp-6789
and the release of all individuals from
scp-6789's effect apply onyui protocol
following its success 05-9's eyes darted
to the corner of the screen he had a new
message from 05-1 reading today race had
detected the following draft for a file
being uploaded for approval to scipnet
i'll just let you draw the conclusions
yourself 05-9 opened the file draft and
it looked just like the first file all
over again in the end the foundation had
succeeded but on some level it had been
a hollow success is all they done to
propagate the loop for another
generation just waiting to happen again
would the heart of mother nature someday
beat again in pain and rage from the
betrayal of her children would
scp-6789 ever truly be defeated or
contained 05-9 decided it was best to
not worry about it too much he grabbed
his office golf equipment and began
teeing up another putt after all you
never know when you won't get another
chance for something like this now go
check out
scp-001 or borrow cycle the full story
compilation and scp-001 scarlet king
dustin blood for more anomalies that
could forever change the world as we
know it